[Musique]
fuck le système acab en anglais all cops
are bastards comprenait tous les flics
sont des bâtards voici les mots inscrits
sur des bouteilles de jus de fruit et
distribués dans les enseignes monoprix
les mercenaires de continuer à proposer
sur ces sujets qui sont si importants
les inscriptions antipolis condamnée
hier par le syndicat alliance qui estime
que ces mots détruisent les relations
entre la police et la population sur
twitter plusieurs consommateurs ont
également été choqués et ont interpellé
monoprix tech emmanuel macron a le dos
tourné xavier bertrand durci le ton ce
matin dans le figaro emmanuel macron n'a
pas été capable de juguler la violence
qui se développe ni de la faire reculer
en matière de sécurité l'échec est
profond je veux bien entendre non passer
le son parce qu'à chaque fois il y va au
bazooka mais j'attends ces propositions
et des propositions sérieuses pour
l'instant il n'y en a pas la première
exigence et ambition gelé parfois
d'ailleurs dit en ces termes je vous le
répète plus de bleus sur le terrain la
police la gendarmerie nos forces de
sécurité intérieure ont un pouvoir
exorbitant et donc il faut le faire dans
la transparence
hier déjà il faut le renforcer parce que
c'est peut-être ce que le président
proposera y compris sur cette question
qui est monté en puissance ces dernières
années de confiance de confiance
fragilisée c'est à ça qu'il fait
référence c'est aussi à la confiance
entre une partie de la population et nos
forces de police qui a été fragilisée
par des affaires telles que celles que
vous avez évoquées est-ce qu'il a
annoncé sur le contrôle la publication
des rapports mais aussi cette délégation
parlementaire ça va permettre d'avoir un
meilleur contrôle un meilleur regard sur
ce qui se passait au pouvoir
disciplinaire je veux nous fixer un
horizon
augmenter significativement
c'est à dire doubler sous dix ans la
présence des policiers et gendarmes sur
la voie publique depuis qu'il ya une
rumeur de ma candidature tout le monde
se met à parler comme moi
valérie pécresse mais même des semaines
par les internautes qui mène insu l'oci
est monsieur barnier qui était
technocrates européens et qui maintenant
clitiques la juridiction européenne
regardez cette élection présidentielle
va peut-être débattre du groupe de
proposition d'un d'un polémiste
d'extrême droite qui veut que les
parents n'aient plus la liberté de choix
du prénom de leurs enfants c'est
absolument ridicule en l'occurrence il
s'agit d'eric zemmour qui effectivement
vos bannières tous les petits mohamed la
fin des cafés sont réservés aux hommes
par une loi non écrite mais appliquée
avec rico - peut-on dire ça eric zemmour
qu'il est né à montreuil venait à
montreuil monsieur zemmour comment vous
pouvez à ce point-là dire pardon de la
grossièreté du matin de telles conneries
c'est un objet médiatique qui se cache
derrière une campagne médiatique et qui
pour l'instant n'a aucun programme si ce
n'est l'hystérisation de la société
française et donc je pense qu'il n'est
pas utile au débat public et laurent
joffrin je ne commence à bien connaître
les schizophrènes pense ouvrir xiam
zemmour mais il veut pas le dire je vous
assure et et oui il en aimait d'été il
est mais là oui mais voulait dire fait
il est comme françois mitterrand on est
bien sûr il est comme
exactement c'est un homme de droite
refoulés google répond près de 900 mille
enseignants ok non c'était juste pour
savoir anne hidalgo veut doubler le
salaire des enseignants vous êtes pour
ou contre
et pourquoi pas le triplé montpellier
allez hop 900 mille voix en moins les
prix ignobel voilà le détournement qui
récompense les études scientifiques les
plus loufoques et tutti attache ce matin
eh bien oui ils ont été décernés ce
week-end et l'un d'entre eux est
français il s'appelle pavlo blavatsky le
voici les français d'origine ukrainienne
il a décroché le prix nobel d'économie
devant le tribunal de paris hier
alexandre benalla stoppé net dans sa
sortie une dizaine de manifestants
l'attendent le but
[Applaudissements]
quelques années plus tard il sortait de
baisser et bien une forte corrélation au
niveau des pays si on voit gouverement
qui est plutôt baisse c'est pratiquement
garantie que ces gouvernement d'un pays
qui est perçu comme corrompu